it's time for the long gene chronic Oh a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
Watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. carl hess press editor
of newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is mr. Henry
Wallace former vice-president of the
United States mr. Wallace I'm sure that
our viewers would be glad to see you
back for our second appearance on the
corona scope tonight sir mr. Hugh I'm
mighty glad to be here because I look on
your program was one of the most
constructive on television today thank
you sir that's very kind and tonight I'm
sure that our viewers would like to have
some of your observations on what you
consider to be the issue to the campaign
last one would be have you made up your
mind for whom you're going to vote well
it's not exactly an issue of the
campaign and I may say that I have not
as yet quite made up my mind I am going
to vote for one of the two leading
candidates have you felt yourself
leaning other way mr. Wallace
well I'm very carefully refraining from
stating publicly as yet as to which way
I am leaning you don't you're dying to
I'm trying to keep an open mind because
I look on myself as a genuine
independent what issues will sway him to
lean one way or the other the particular
issue that would sway me is as to which
candidate comes out with the methods
which I deem most constructive for
promoting a secure peace
and domestic prosperity well now have
you has General Eisenhower for instance
said anything that interested you along
that line General Eisenhower has said he
was for peace
he hasn't indicated that precisely how
he would attain a secure peace combined
with domestic prosperity it's not was
Stevenson also I assume is for peace and
domestic prosperity but neither one nor
the other has come out as yet with a
definite method of attaining the
security you feel that there's a single
definite method you have something in
mind yourself yes I very definitely do
have something combined well so here
spoke of yourself as being an
independent and that you haven't yet
made up your mind how do you feel that a
great many people haven't yet made up
their minds I think a much larger
percentage of the population than usual
has not made up its mind as yet and do
you think that that independence should
be in this position now do you see
independence in some peculiar role in
this campaign I think the independence
are important in all campaigns but
especially so in this one and I know
they will I hope they will follow my
example
and not state exactly how I vote why sir
because if they will hold their fire as
it were it will be an inducement for
both candidates to become more specific
specific in terms of the all-important
constructive issue and one of the
candidates win without making these
specific statements the how important
are these independence I think there are
new is really important in this
particular campaign I noticed mr. Sam
LaBelle in one of the New York
newspapers has said welt on that at
considerable length and that Elmo Roper
has gone into a great detail on it both
bluebell's analysis and ropers analysis
indicate to me quite clearly that
have more importance this year than
usual on this business of smoking in the
house sir what particular plan do you
have what would you like to hear them
say well I feel the all-important issue
was from the standpoint of domestic
prosperity in the long run and from the
standpoint of world peace is recognizing
that in that vast area on the southern
border of Russia and China the dominant
problem is an agricultural problem these
people are very poor they predict
because they produce only about one
fiftieth as much as the American farmer
their misery has been increasing and the
Communists are exploiting that misery
and if those people alone that entire
southern border in the desperation of
their misery should succumb to the
communist propaganda then the world
would become overbalanced many great
disadvantage people you mean India and
Iran that's something like 500 million
people in that area I said oh yes
definitely 500 going all the way across
to northern Africa you think that's the
the key area at the moment now the area
that absolutely we must fight Russian
influence in that area yeah well I'd put
it specifically that's a way to fight
Russian influence in that area is really
to get close to the people who are on
the land you see more than 80% of the
people in that area are farmers and they
are 99 percent I would say using
backward methods well they're also
prisoners of a sort now how do you get
close to them in their condition of
servitude to the Soviet Union now I'm
referring to the people on the southern
border the people live below the line
yes it's it's below China I'm referring
to the people in India and Afghanistan
and all the way across does this mean we
give up China no I'd say that the way to
gain China the only way in which
effectively we can gain China now is to
demonstrate what we can do on the border
areas I do think that the Nationalist
government in Formosa
yes
putting forth a very good effort at the
present time to gain the support of the
Formosan farmers well now with this 500
million that is they they do recognize
that you have to give the people on the
land a stake in the land something that
they feel as their own in other words
you have 500 million people at least and
80% of them are farmers so your
particular interest is in four or five
hundred million of farm people and you
want to raise their their living
standards is that right yes that is
correct I don't say that is the sole
issue but I say that a list that
particular issue is recognized that all
other methods of gaining secure secure
peace for us will fail and that is
military methods alone can't do it I
recognized the need in view of starlings
a statement I think is October 14th just
a few days ago means that we do have to
be fully prepared for every contingency
you may remember the precise statement
did or something to the effect that that
Russia was standing behind the
Communists in every Western country how
do you interpret them well it was a very
alarming statement because it would
indicate that at the moment stalling
stalling believes that there is going to
be war and he wants to have a fifth
column in every Western concept I I do
hope that Stalin comes to his senses and
abandons that position because that does
seem to foreclose peace at the moment as
that's rather disillusioning to you sir
you've been friendly toward the Soviet
Union that's at various periods in your
life had well I I have felt that the
dominant issue ever since 1942 and that
the dominant post-war issue would be
whether or not we could come to a
friendly understanding with Russia I
still say it's the dominant issue and I
regret exceedingly that
that Stalin has made a statement of this
sort and that Russia has been taking an
attitude that seems to make peace very
difficult well to come back to your your
plan sir for helping to raise the the
food standard of these people if
Stalin's plan isn't it as you understand
it now is to helped is to try to destroy
us by inflation is one of the things
what are the weapons against us isn't it
well that's what this state wouldn't
indicate well I felt right along that
that the Stalinist Marxist say being so
steeped in their brand of economics
would try to destroy us without war
either by the deflation route or the
inflation route not inflation and the
state would would indicate to me that
they feel the best bet is the inflation
route maintaining the tension at the
maximum so that we will spend vast sums
of money on armaments well how can we go
about raising the living standards of
four or five hundred million farmers
without increasing the dangers of
inflation at home I think the pattern
for doing that is given by Nelson
Rockefellers program through this
international agricultural Association
Corporation in Brazil and Venezuela
which means that you use technicians
American and Native technicians working
hand in hand using local money as much
as possible to make supervised loans to
the local farmers now that doesn't take
an awful lot to be the u.s. capital or
united nations capital but it does take
a lot of training of both american
technicians and the native technicians
to do the job i know something about
this kind of thing because I saw that
hard work in the old Farm Security
Administration the supervised loans for
farmers does not that method does not
need to take an awful lot of money is it
fair to describe but I would hope this
generalizing if he becomes present that
his brother Milton would be there at his
right hand because he knows exactly how
this is done
and if Stevenson becomes present I could
I could name certain people that could
help here
well in this case though your aid
program it seems to me would run smack
into a Russian barrier of actual
sabotage and certainly propaganda how do
we overcome that well of course is you
can beat propaganda with propaganda but
the best way of meeting propaganda of
all is to produce results and I think
our extension people know how it is is
that you produce actual results of
getting them to produce twice as much as
they can producing and then the second
exactly a struggle for men's minds at
this point it's a struggle first for
men's stomachs and through the stomachs
their minds you've got to get their
stomachs because there's a population
explosion coming out the mouse out
running the food and unless we recognize
that there's the dyers disaster coming
to all of us including Russia and they
say well III as one of the world's great
food scientist sir then as I understand
it you think that we are specific very
particular well-equipped to fight this
battle for innovation so well-equipped
the Communists can use propaganda and
make promises which they can never
fulfill about given the land tomb of
this that the other thing but we are the
ones that can produce results well thank
you very much for being with us tonight
sir in the opinions who've heard our
speakers expressed tonight are entirely
their own the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Cronus Cove was
mr. William Bradford Huie and mr. Carl
Hess our distinguished guest was mr.
Henry Wallace former vice president of
the United States